c'est une mise au point et c'est une
demande que j'ai faite non pas à
l'accompagnatrice scolaire voilée mais à
la présidente de région qu'on a dit
julien audy l'a exclu une
accompagnatrice voiles et j'ai demandé
la présidente de l'association dis je il
ya lui qui m'en bêtises mais il faut se
resituer dans le contexte parce que moi
j'ai entendu hier ninon et le grand
frère sur le plateau d'un long tir voilà
avant-hier ce il faut se remettre dans
le contexte moi je me remets dans le
contexte on était quelques jours après
l'attentât de la préfecture de police de
paris où quatre de nos policiers sont
tombés et il y avait un hommage le matin
même au conseil régional donc pour pour
ces policiers et l'après midi on a cette
accompagnatrice qui vient s'installer
dans une enceinte démocratique qui vient
bafouer nos principes ah ben là bas tu
viens bafouer nos principes donc je suis
intervenu ça va des quarante ans que et
lloret de mar après sur la forme on peut
on peut évidemment bien s'interroger sur
la forme est-ce que c'était pertinent ou
non un mais en revanche sur gérer sur la
provocation parce que c'était une
provocation bien évidemment que moi je
m'insurge contre toutes les provocations
islamistes qui visent à quoi qui vise à
nous habituer à un symbole qui est
l'emblème de l'islamisme d'une idéologie
mortifère que nous ne pouvons pas
accepter qu'ils l'asservissement des
femmes la relégation des femmes j'ai
contacté notre titre de retirer la crds
ci vise sur julien
didac si vous avez lui dire combien j'ai
envie de les mains des essais d'hier il
absolument vous rencontrer et vous dire
ce qu'elle pense oui parce que ben merci
syrie l'un parce qu'il ya quand toi qui
donne la parole aux femmes qui portent
va donc ça me fait plaisir puisque vous
avez soit parlée sur les bateaux
malheureusement n'y a pas de
contradiction en face moi je voulais
savoir est-ce que vous pensez que je
suis islamistes parce que vous venez de
faire un discours en disant que voies
légales islamisme donc j'aimerais bien
vous entendre sur la question déjà je ne
vous connais pas oui j'ai
patiemment l'arrivée mais cette fois
mieux que vous savez ce que vous portez
quelles que soient vos motivations et
vos motivations vous savez moi des
femmes voilées j'en connais beaucoup
j'en connais dans ma ville de sens vous
savez je suis pas allergique voilà vous
avez derrière
il ne nie pas les gens je suis pas les
régions ni de patch mais j'ai des
valeurs j'ai des principes et j'ai une
conception de mon pays et de la femme
mais vous savez moi la femme elle n'est
pas vous allez moi elle n'est pas sous
une prison tissu des droits mais c'est
soit vous pour étaler sur mais vos
convictions ils sont pas au dessus de la
constitution moi j'aurais bien que les
personnes en fait elles comprennent ça
aujourd'hui c'est que clairement d'un
règlement intérieur en plus avaient dit
des mensonges j'aimerais bien savoir en
fait au moment où vous avez prononcé ces
paroles est-ce que vous avez conscience
que c'était des mensonges parce que si
vous le mettez ce inquiétant si vous le
saviez pas c'est encore pire parce que
c'est l'ignorance non mais il ya aucun
mensonge et ensuite sur ce que vous
portez six ans aux attendes est normal
y'a pas il ya pas le département sont
recensés sur la mediapad mensonge nos
principes républicains et le vivre en
france le vivre en france n'est pas le
voile que vous le vouliez ou non enfin
d'autres ailleurs nos traditions notre
culture notre mode de vie notre
conception et la femme ne permet pas le
voile islamique que vous le vouliez ou
non même et mes patients je sais que
j'en suis bien je viens vous ça vous
dérange vraiment l'idéal avec ça le
dérange grand bien lui fasse je suis pas
là pour faire plaisir si on n'est pas
content et je suis tombé c'est son
problème à lui à ce monsieur c'est
plutôt en fait c'est comme on dit faut
que la honte at change de camp c'est
vous qui avez un problème vous allez
voir un psychologue vous avions parlé
mais moi je ne fais rien pas respecter
les lois de mon pays ne vous en déplaise
je
voulais juste rajouter quelque chose
passe alors à beaucoup de la forme mais
pas sur le fond s'il vous plaît c'est un
mensonge ce que vous avez dit elle avait
droit de garder son voile pourquoi
messieurs o2 qui êtes vous pour lui en
interdire dites moi alors déjà oui
malheureusement elle avait le droit
continue de la loi de le porter dans une
sortie scolaire indique que je trouve
une aberration parce que les signes
religieux ostentatoires sont interdits
dans le cadre scolaire mais dans les
sorties scolaires ou motorisés tués ce
qui est une hérésie l'absurdité et
ensuite dans le cadre oui
malheureusement du conseil régional
s'était autorisé moi j'ai relevé et
j'espère que j'ai interpellé à la
présidente de région pour lui dire qu au
nom de nos principes républicains et
laïques ce n'était pas concevable
déjà c'était pas concevable continue du
moment où nous étions c'est-à-dire
quelques jours après un attentat manqué
mal gamme ça c'est des civils bien sûr
que s'il m'entendait pas dire qu'il n'y
a pas de rapports alors ça vous ne
pouvez pas dire peut être mais je
comprends je comprends qu'on tenait la
corde à quoi tend des jeux pendant ce
jeu je comprends ce que vous non je suis
pas dangereux
vous aidez votre discours en tout cas
c'est pas moi qui commet des attentats
est passé pendant d'une idéologie
ce que j'aimerais vous dire si parce que
j'aimerais juste que votre compte je
comprends votre point n'est pas ça qui
est inquiétant en fait je comprends mais
excusez moi alors allez-y julian je
comprends votre point de vue parce que
vous estimez c'est ma liberté saleh
s'est pas tu sais moi aller au bout s'il
vous plaît voilà une réponse vous verrez
je suis pas méchant je vais juste aller
au bout d'un raisonnement vous dites
c'est votre liberté est-ce que vous avez
la même liberté pour les femmes qui dans
le monde par exemple en afghanistan par
exemple en iran qui veulent s'extirper
du voile et qui veulent retirer le voile
est ce que pour vous avez la même
liberté vous considérez la que ces
femmes là ont le droit j'ai moins le
droit de retirer le mot que j'ai la
chance justement d'être française et
pouvoir justement le droit de
l'autoriser en fait je suis libre etc
vous en faites qui met à jour sa
question exemple sur ces pays là je vous
dise quoi que je défends je suis content
je suis pour la liberté en france tom
doit partout dans le monde donc vous
vous souvenez il ya des disney les
femmes qui au nom de la liberté retirent
leurs voiles en afghanistan et c'est
bien sûr mais bien s'amuser mais on ne
va pas me féliciter pour soi mais bien
sûr que vous faites ici mais bien sûr
parce qu'on aurait néanmoins ce que je
vous dis au nom des principes après au
nom des principes islamiques et chez
grasset hollande déjà du 6 mai mais bien
sûr que vous êtes française mais disent
pourquoi mais vous avez une carte
d'identité française bien sauf que vous
ne respectez pas retenu de votre
accoutrement dans les traditions la
culture le mode de vie notre vie
français il ya huit mois parce que le
voile c'est pas un vêtement que trop
grand le voile c'est pas un jogging le
voile c'est même pas un emblème
religieux le voile aujourd'hui ces
humbles et médiatique